[Applause]
guys holy sh we are a resilient team
gentlemen we are resilient we're going
to find a way to win they freaking came
out and they fought us but we fought
harder and we went and got the win
that's outstanding that's division win
number two I got one game ball give me
this all right Hey listen to make the
rally that we did and to come back man
we needed some stops we get the stops
offense we go down we strike we need
another stop we get to stop Hutch where
you at
[Applause]
brother motion I'm so proud of everybody
man I'm really excited about this year
I'm really excited about this year I
think we're going to do some special
especially with the adversity we
just dealt with how we overcame it man
got to keeping pushing we by week let's
go win all three 1 2 three